hello and welcome to another Evernote
tutorial today mates and a question for
one of my youtube viewers love you guys
his name is Greg he wrote in to say nice
video excellent job
I notice you you have many notebooks
I've watched other videos which indicate
using less notebooks and more tags what
are your thoughts I'm struggling a bit
with this thanks so Greg I like to use
notebooks instead of tags I'll show you
how I use it specifically it's not
necessarily the right way to do it just
how I found it super helpful so let me
load up my Evernote here these are all
my different notebooks and I like to use
it like I use my computer I use Evernote
like I would use my computer so I have
different folders for all my different
files for all my different ideas and
then I can do a quick search if I need
to find something specific so sometimes
when I'm searching for something I I
don't know when this Celia key word I'm
looking for
I want to see it in a group of
everything else that relates to that
topic and so it's helpful to have it in
a specific folder and those are the
notebooks and sometimes I want to find
something very specific and I have a key
word and so I can use that by doing the
full search so let me show you some
examples so these are my notebooks I
like using stacks so for example this is
my TDS notes doc and TS as an investment
I've made in a salsa dancing company so
this is a simple example of some of the
things that we might be working on some
looking at some t-shirts you instruct
your TV ready like these are kind of I
use it as two do's these are two dudes
that I need to get done or that we're
working on with the business and within
the stock so everything in this stock is
tedious note so that's all related to
the business and then I can have
different notebooks within there that I
can can follow up on so for example
these might be my tedious notes these
might be the things that we need to work
on I can go back and to the archive
folder and these are some of the things
that we may have been working on before
so looking at downtown locations or
YouTube mixes or New York's also schools
all these different ideas that we've
we've already implemented but I wanted
to keep a record on it so what I would
do here is this might be the to do and
when I'm finished with it I would just
right click and move note into the the
folder here for archive or just drag it
in as well so
would be there so that's why I find it
super helpful because I have a list here
of all the different things that are on
the to do and I'm a you know maybe want
to work on the TV or may want to look at
a Weber or may want to look at special
events whatever it is it's basically a
list and every month when I meet with
the founder all open up my TDS notes and
we'll talk about what the progress is on
all these different projects so it's
easy to see the kind of the group the
next will use it another example
business receipts so I'll keep receipts
in different folders from 2008 all the
way to 2013 and I do it by you know q1
q2 q3 q4 and I can look through and find
a specific receipt if I know a date
range that I'm looking at I want to kind
of group them together and then finally
another example let me look at maybe my
vacation so I use it for personal
reasons as well and might throw
different vacations so that the the
stack is vacation these might be
different vacations that have that I've
gone on and I can click on any one so
you know New York or Europe recently
what I'll do here is I'll find different
things that I'm doing so it'll be you
know the hotel I'm saying on Barcelona
different salsa clubs I like the dance
obviously what to do in each city so you
know if when we get to Rome
here's Rome here's the picture here's
what to do lots of interesting things
and I have this on my phone as well so
when we actually land in the city I can
go around you know I can look at my this
is a hotel
this is Barcelona so each city you know
has different things that I can go and
explore and I'd like having it all in
one folder so when I'm on my phone or on
my laptop I can quickly pull up the
whole Europe folder and find out exactly
what's going on the next day and where
we should go and I have a you know
specific map that I can look at so I can
find out where I need to get so that's
why I use the notebooks the other way I
find is super easy to get access to a
specific thing is through the search so
I always make sure that everything I put
in to my Evernote is full-text
searchable if you're using a scanner you
might have to enable it if you're taking
pictures off your phone it should be
automatic and at the top right here you
can search all notes so if you're
looking for something really specific so
say I need to find so I put an example
here say I need to find the Staples
receipt
I could put in staples and it'll pull up
the receipt so then I can scroll through
there's not the one that I wanted so I
bought some scissors or you know my visa
statement or whatever receipt that I
have these are pictures that I that I
took what you just using my phone and it
does a full-text search which is more
what I do now
but before I used to scan each one in
and so you get that kind of picture
coming up and so I find the combination
of storing things in notebooks it's kind
of like folders on my computer it's an
easy way that I'm used to and if I need
to see everything all together for that
folder like if I'm on a trip or like if
I'm meeting the CEO of this business I
need to talk about it I can do it easily
there and if we need to find something
specific then I can use the full text
search and it pulls up near
instantaneous results and I haven't had
to dig in deeper so don't really use
tags that much that's just part of my
workflow I'm sure a lot of people have
had success using it but I haven't found
that I needed it I find this kind of
solves all the needs I have just
combining notebooks and the full-text
search so hopefully that answered your
question there Gregg and if you guys
like this video please give it a thumbs
up below if you have a question about
how I use it or another question related
to Evernote leave it below make a video
response thank you so much and I'll see
you soon